as we touched on earlier in this class
rendering pages quickly is super
important let's think about this for a
moment because if you can request data
asynchronously you open up a range of
new ways for making fast page loads
let's think about this Facebook for food
app over here where I've got my favorite
cereal favorite pasta favorite meal and
how I like my eggs it's displaying
custom content based on me being the
user take a look at some possible steps
for rendering this app and what order
could we run these steps to get the
first pixels on the screen over here as
fast as possible just to be clear
generic refers to HTML that would be the
same for all users that would be the
HTML for let's say favorite cereal
favorite pasta it could also even be CSS
for you know how to style this image and
how to style all this text unique HTML
refers to things like the strings for my
name the strings for all my favorite
foods because this is unique to me
specifically